this video was brought to you by social
point
I'm dying and Edgar
and yeah I'm sick I need you to make the
views coming down whereabouts I will
cook you something real nice make you
feel better
you stay here give me the views do this
last thing for me
my child go
sup guys this is Edgar this five weird
stuff online I'm gonna use all the items
to cook something for Porter pie with a
little bit of my own ingredients
something to make them feel better let's
go alright thank you good tanker stop
so now it's time to add item number one
one of my secret ingredients
alright it's time to crack the eggs I
don't have anything to crack the eggs
with oh wait I'm number one
Hilary Nutcracker item number two salt
and magic salt sprinkle combined with
salt in the thing yeah awesome you gotta
have the bacon salt that's coming in
quite nicely grandma's favorite oh she
lost this alright to give it that
nice flavor you put some ice cream in it
it's really good like sytem bacon delish
love it oh yeah this is the
stuff
Oh can't forget about good stuff yeah
that's right that's it that's it oh oh
boy this can be a good king let's go me
around the stick that's a lot of wee boy
all right now it's item number 64 time
to whisk the cake
wait I think we need more tequila that's
it baby
that's it that's it it's going to make
photo pie felt better now let's put that
in the RV let's take a quick look
and see how poets is doing when poet is
sick it likes to play world chess wall
chef is a little really fun game that
always makes him happier and look even
purchasing this game there's even the
bro diner Wow
you think he'd spent too much time on
this game but I think there's no such
thing
check our old chef down into the
description this game is really fun I'll
give it 5 out of 5 pause for this pause
now let's unpause
bones I made you this cake good Gary you
brought me my favorite cake trying
you'll feel better I promise
oh it tastes nice I feel better already
hey kick you came back to me
oh that say that's my boy oh you like
that yeah I bet you do I saved your life
boats I saved your life
oh okay well oh man for myself I don't
think it creamy yeah where's me where I
get you find same ride want you to do